– What would you say to him is one proof
that he can look at to confirm that
the Quran is not a man-made book
and Islam is not a man-made religion,
it is indeed from the divine,
being an expert in the Quran?
– Well, lots can be said,
I'd start off by my own journey to share.
– Can you hear him Andrew?
– Yeah.
– Nice talking to you.
I think that what I like to do
when I meet with audiences,
professors of other faiths
and intellectuals, anybody
is that I like to invite them to explore
the Quran intellectually and critically.
that's an invitation that the Quran gives.
It's interesting that people perceive religion
as something that you have to be
indoctrinated into
and you have to follow it as the dictates are
and you don't have to actually
critically ask any questions
or think and contemplate.
And the Quran is kind of unique in the way
that it presents its message because
it's constantly saying
"Don't you then think?
Don't you contemplate?
Haven't you asked questions?"
This is a book for those
who seek to have answers.
It's not actually asking you to shut
your brain off and accept what it's saying,
it's actually asking you
to contemplate its message
so it stands really unique in that sense.
Since it offered that invitation to me,
I didn't come to the Quran first
as someone who believes in it,
I wanted to figure this thing out
and you know trying to make sense of it.
And many of the things that
I struggled with in philosophy
when I was a student of philosophy,
they started getting unraveled as I was getting
deeper and deeper in my study of the Quran
it just started kind of untying
a lot of those knots
and it's also remarkable that
some of the biggest addictions
that people suffer from, every one of them
is targeting one after the other in the Quran.
Some of the things that
like gambling for example,
alcohol for example,
intoxication for example,
like each of these things is targeting
and you think it's not just solving
a Muslim problem,
it's solving a human problem,
it's solving a societal problem
and solving a global problem
by targeting each of these specific things.
The other thing that really fascinated me
I ended up writing a book on it,
ended up getting taught
around the world AlhamduliLlah,
it's even being used
in one of the Islamic studies courses
at Harvard now.
It's "Divine speech",
it's a book I dedicated along
with my student to why is this book,
why am I believing that it's divine,
what's making me think this?
and I wrote it for
a non-muslim audience actually.
It's a little bit academic but the point of it
was there are there are elements to this book
and the way that it's structured
that if you went to the library
or you got on Amazon and bought yourself
a translation of the Quran,
you started reading it,
you think the subject is kind of
going all over the place,
it's not staying on the same subject,
it's saying some profound things
but the organization seems
unlike anything I've ever read.
and that was one of the things
that baffled me at first like,
"Why is it organized in this way?"
And so one of the areas of my study
became the organization of the Quran,
why is it organized in this way?
Why is God talking in this disarray?
And what I discovered was
something absolutely breathtaking,
that it's it's got a symmetrical structure,
that you'll have a chapter for example,
that's hundreds of verses
like Bakara is 286 verses,
it's an oral tradition
so it wasn't written first,
it was recited and pronounced
and memorized in that way,
amounts to about 50 pages in Arabic.
But if you study the subject matter,
the nine subjects that are occurring
in this long 50 page discourse
are like subject one
is directly tied to subject nine
and two to eight and three to seven
and four to six and five
right center in the middle,
like there's an incredible
three-dimensional structure
to the way the arguments being presented.
Human beings we think linear,
"I'm going to make point a,
then I'm going to make point b,
then I'm going to make point c,
that's how I organize my thoughts",
and unless you write something down
and say you know "What I'm going to do this
and just for fun I'm going to do abc
and then go cba".
Even doing that in six sentences is hard for me
as I'm sitting here talking to you
because my brain isn't wired that way,
but this a millennium and a half old tradition
has got multiple Surahs
and multiple chapters,
where this kind of a structure
is demonstrated over
and over again and other kinds of structures.
This is not possible for a human being
to do linguistically, it's not possible,
I'm a student of linguistics,
it's just not possible these kinds
of structures, this kind of organization,
that that's one of the things
I wrote about in the book
and I started ended up
teaching courses on this stuff.
But for just just take a step back level,
my invitation to anybody
is put your preconceived notions aside,
take what you may have heard about Islam,
what you may have thought about it
from your own faith traditions point of view,
put all of that aside and I wouldn't even invite
somebody to read the Quran to accept Islam.
Read the Quran neutrally
and get a first an unbiased impression
and I would think it's really
difficult to not walk away
truly being moved by what
you're what you're being exposed to,
truly being hit by what you're exposed to.
The final thing I'll say is there is
a huge tragedy in the world today
that even most Muslims aren't as aware
of the Quran as they should be.
So Muslims don't become
a really good representation
of the contents of the book.
So even disconnecting yourself
from the Muslim bias,
"I'm just going to read this for myself,
with no other influences as much as possible".
At the end of the day human beings
are going to have some bias or the other,
but as much as I can consciously be disconnected
from bias and give it a shot and read it
I think that would be my invitation to anybody.
– Andrew, any question, any final question
you'd like to ask him while he's here?
What happened was because
we got delayed with the program,
next guest was coming in, so I'm with you.
But this is amazing,
you can look him up actually online
and you'll see a ton of his videos.
– I'm going to, I'm going to read
that book as well,
because it was really interesting
what you were saying.
– After the show I'd like to send you
a copy as a gift.
– And also your invitation is exactly
the way I would have done it anyway,
I would have read it, I'm going to read it,
I've yet to read the Quran,
but it's certainly something I'm going to do,
I'm going to read it without
a preconceived notion,
without a preconceived idea
and I think that's the best way to do things
because you're right,
there's too much bias in the world.
From what I know,
I think we just talked about for the last hour,
from what I know,
I have absolute respect for the religion
and respect for the faith
and I've been very blessed to be on the show,
so thank you very much for having me,
I appreciate it.
– Thank you.
I cannot leave without giving you a gift,
if you're not yet Muslim and you're tuning in
to see what these Muslims are talking about
and you like a free copy of the Quran
go and visit theDeenShow.com,
we'll take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us
at 1-800-662-4752.
We'll see you next time, until then
peace be with you, Assalamu Aleikum.
And if you liked this episode of the Deen show
like this video, share this video
far and wide and support us on our Patreon page
so we can continue this work,
thank you for tuning in,
peace be with you, Assalamu Aleikum.